do you think the future of sexuality is
fluid I think coming Generations won't
torture themselves when they Define
their behaviors some people may spend
one stage of their lives as heterosexual
and another as asexual and even in
others may be homosexual so is it worth
making those distinctions at all only if
those distinctions serve you
some people feel that sexuality defines
them you know as a person others don't
you know but both camps are totally
correct
as this is for you it's from my homegirl
Fanta she created a jewelry line and she
wanted you and Mom to have pieces from
the collection cool tell her I said
thanks okay oh and the charm is for like
Good Fortune like money health love how
does that work girl it doesn't it's a
sales hook but it's pretty and it won't
turn your wrist green
Hill so I have this friend that I have a
crush on
and I think that's been nice to me but
hasn't said that
what do I do does a friend have a name
Lucia
that's a pretty name
tell me more about her
well she's an eighth grader she's smart
she has a nerdy sense of humor like me
she doesn't take crap from anyone
are you surprised
I mean I'm surprised you're having
feelings for somebody since you're
always so busy trying to save the world
but no
I'm not surprised that you're gay I mean
I'm attracted to girls but I haven't
totally ruled out boys which is why I'm
afraid to tell Mom and Dad because I
haven't got it figured out and I don't
want them to think that I'm just in some
Fades you know you're 12. you don't have
to have everything figured out and you
don't have to tell anybody if you don't
want to
but I'm happy you told me
I'm gonna really miss you who
I'm gonna miss you too
and look I'll always be here if you ever
need to talk okay
give me a hug
s
[Music]
hahaha